cabinet biggio is going to lead it off
for the blue chase his average is up to
277.
there's a breaking ball hit through the
vacated left side and biggio is a board
with a base hit here's randall grichik
he gets a curveball and lines it into
left for a base hit and a good start for
the blue jays back-to-back singles and
the bases are loaded here is goriel
a fly ball to right field it is well hit
over the head of verdugo and off the
base of the fence
here comes biggio here comes gretchen
hernandez is into third on a two-run
double and the blue jays have an early
lead well with the two runs that louis
curiel just drove in he has gone over
the 100 rbi mark in his career at 101
now and only three blue jays got to 100
quicker than gorille did two down two in
scoring position here is danny janssen
the 1-1 to janssen pounding ball on the
left side of the diamond pass the dive
of bogarts into left field to base in
berdugo comes charging forward he wants
to throw to the plate curiel slides in
the blue jays attacked on two throw down
to second jansen's tank out by peraza
and that will retire this side bogart's
hitting 271. six homers 17 knocked in
anderson's pitch fastball swung on hit
well left center field way back and off
the wall in left center on a hop played
by the center fielder hernandez and it's
an easy stand-up double for xander
bogarts zander in scoring position with
nobody out and the batter is mitch
moreland
trying to go up the middle he will for a
base hit bogart's rounding third he will
score without a throw and moreland stays
at it 19th rbi that'll make it a four to
one game
now we've got some changes on the
infield for the blue jays so travis shaw
has left the game
brandon drury has moved from second to
third
and joe panic as you can see is now at
second zander with a second double he
has scored the sox only run
goes the other way and he drops in a
single to right field so
xander bogart's with a multi-hit game
already here in the fourth inning
moreland with an rbi single his first
time up and the pitch is a curve hit
deep toward right center field up the
gap it hits on the grass one hops the
wall it'll score xander and mitch cruz's
into second with an rbi double and it's
4-2
rule to pass ball and up the middle
flagged down by panic airborne throwing
got him oh he's safe
first base umpire called him out but we
shall see and if they overturn the call
the run will score the original look
looked like he beat it by quite a bit
that's a great player obviously but is
he going to get him at first base
yeah that's slow motion
the ball just stopped in the air yeah
ball hit the dirt
and just kind of stopped
right there and bradley hits the bag and
then the balls in the glove the jackie
bradley will have himself a hit and an
rbi that chases in moreland second and
third two down and the batter will be
guerrero
and hard on the ground wide a third a
base hit into left into score is espinal
right behind him is biggio it's a two
run single for vladimir guerrero jr
vladi hits this ball straight into the
ground but he hits it hard enough to
skip it past the outstretched armor
rafael devers perfectly in between
devers and bogarts espinal and vizio
score that'll extend guerrero's hit
streak to eight straight
walk and games will face the new pitcher
there's a high fly ball center field
racing back hernandez he won't get it
it's over his head
moreland chugging his way into third
base he's going to stop there that'll be
a double for vasquez over the head of
hernandez jackie bradley jr has grounded
out he's also single in a run tonight
bounty ball up the middle of bay set
moreland is in to score
vazquez will be held at third the throws
up the line it'll be an rbi single for
jbj and the red sox inch a little closer
oh it's vasquez at third jackie the time
run at second peraza the go ahead run on
it first product choking up slightly on
the bat open stance and the 1-0
swing a hard shot right side throw for a
base hit here comes vasquez and the
throw to the plate
is too late the bases remain loaded it
too hard for jackie to score from second
base so it is six five bradley at third
peraza at second verdugo at first for
raffy devers
and he tags that one hot shot down the
line that's going to go all the way to
the corner up against the fence
jackie bradley is in peraza coming
around to score and all the way down to
third as three runs across the plate is
rafael denver's and the red sox leaded
and he rifles this ball look out wow
look at the bounce over the head
of guerrero in first base this ball goes
all the way down the line to the wall
you knew they were going to clear the
bases you just knew it and raffi's on
his horse all the way to third base is
clearing triple there for stand up
triple for devon and the red sox turn
this game around 8-6 now bringing up jd
martinez
off the end of the bat he's going to fly
that one to right field
biggio has it lined up
here comes the run dever's trying to
score the throw home won't get him
give the rbi to jd martinez and the red
sox lead it nine to six nancy oscar
hernandez 0 for three with a walk walked
and scored back in the four run first
inning
and this one has hit a long way to right
field opposite field home run today
oscar hernandez and it's nine to seven
and it's a four scene fastball and watch
the swing he stays on it and
i mean he's targeting center field right
field right there he didn't try to pull
it at all and he's rewarded with a home
run
2-2 pitch to tolez
swing and a miss and that'll do it the
red sox win it 9-7 the final on 13 hits
both sides with 13 red sox with a huge
sixth inning and they take game one here
in toronto